re ん
自強ギャルパークプロ野球
ええええええ
ああああああ
こんにちははじめしゃちょーで同意したか今のこのゲームと現実が混ざった感じ今日は
何度ですねパワーフロー猫のピッチングマシーンを使ってすごいことをしようと思って
ますそうですよねー
そうですうん
本日は実況パワフルプロ野球デー
自分が育成した投手等リアルな方もののプロ野球選手を実際に対決させるという夢の
ようなありえねー企画です
ゲームの世界とこの現実の世界がついに
まずある時が来たんです入っいうわけですね
こういうことでせっかくやるので一人でやっててもちょっとねもったいないなぁと思う
ので今日は仲間を呼んでおります
こちらの皆さんです選手の入場ですさあ選手の入場です
メンバーは一番空知2番鈴鹿は3番みー立つ
4番太郎アゲアゲそして5番はじめしゃちょー
はじめしゃちょーチーム以上のメンバーです
よくはああ
私肇社長園のマネージャー
させていただきまー鈴川絢子と申します
ni
させ
中田が肇社長のお友達というちょっと1人が物足りないんだと仲間を2人読んできまし
た
アバンティーザプラチナよろしくお願いしまーす
応援団そ応援なんて降っはい応援隊長のさとちんですよろしくお願いしゃーすあああ
春初戦僕のおふた方が今が始め社協の呼び掛けで集まってくださった一般ユーザー代表
のお二人へございました一般 t トーン
vita つです今回もよろしくお願いします
ano hi ハリアー
youtube やってますああ
アゲアゲですよろしくお願い
今回は他社のマネージャーなんですけれども一応私の選手を育成してきたのでいい
ちょっと投げさせて頂いた停電を付けた
ありがとうございます
これから列車やっていくんですかやっぱり皆さん
肝心なのが入って待ったらだというあいけどねぇ
エアー
早速所の退社ないてを発表したいと思います愛では始めましょう
ベース冗談対戦相手は誰ですかー
選手の入場です
バターわー
4番
べっどう
befor
アメちゃん北家いいねんっ
tee
よかったらめちゃんだ you can あみちゃんに向けて先生布告の一言お願いし
ます
ヒュンダでお願いしますフィットの相棒が中いくからな
ロザンヌ
4強ギャルパーするプロ野球
さあということで両チームが整列して試合開始です
なお今回の実況リアルパーフープロ野球は肇社長チームの5人それぞれが実際にゲーム
で育成したピッチャーとケーキ時代数々の球団で4番を務めた
アレックスラミレスとの合板勝負です
はじめしゃちょーチームの5人それぞれはランレストの1打席勝負
アウトにできれば肇社長チームにポイントきっと以上なら
ラミレス選手日光ポイントフォアボールデッドボールは lavie s 21
ポイントが入り
光院跡に合計ポイントの高かった方が勝利となります
ではここでプレゼントのお知らせですはじめしゃちょーチームの勝利でグリーン泥色
ランネスの勝利で自動薫陶を全員へプレゼントします
ではピッチングマシーンの再現性の高さをご紹介しましょう
まず球速は80キロから140キロ
選択可能変化球のカツは7種類まさに育成したピッチャーの能力そのままディアビに
再現できる素晴らしい環境がとドロっております
なお各ポジションの種類にはご覧のように実際の野球経験者の皆さんに守っていただき
ます
実況は小笠原急いでお送りします緊張感が高まってまいりましたスタジアム
いよいよ試合開始です
そして注目の一人となるピッチャーわー
チャージャー一人目空チート8でラミちゃんの情報
はいございます早打ちの傾向があり2007年の初級地の打率は5割は超えられたよぞ
やいきますよね z にストレートを狙ってくると思うのでてことは
変化球変化球変化球を線全部変化系縛りでいきますあの木月3何をフォークを体得して
いるので全休フォークであるおすすめです
心理戦立いや200
久津即先発がちーがチングマシーンに迎えます
ユーチューバーた選びですリアルは勝つかそれともデジタルムーン一部赤塚
世紀の一戦です
ゆっくりと打席に向かうラミです
まずは多くが自慢育ち育成選手育ちの投球です
宣言通り
頭でいきます果たして狙い通り初球地を回避して打ち取ることができるのか
登壇
大通りフォークいやー切れスムーズによく見ました
アポロくちいましーの実力を元フォームラオウに見せつけました
通り2球目もフォークでいきましょう
恋をしけがを乗り越え時には人体改造までするパープロサクセス頭皮
その力を見せつけることができるのか
おっと私てのフォークを見送りストライク
ラミレスそう
動悸の症状を見せております
なんと2球で追い込みましたパープルの変化球の一例についていけないのカラミです
じっ心を持って東津留次が3球目
ゆっくりとホームに入る
に3球三振
これを受注する前になる
割と打ち取られましたいっ
さぁ続いて2人目私鈴鹿ラガー
私の選手へストレート140キロ
へさらにシュート進化カーブシュートスっており
大切と言っていきたいとおもいます
第1打席は入部力を見せてた肇社長チーム
せず次のピッチャーはマネージャー k ピッチャーの鈴鹿ばーい
今日はカープのヒロインともいえるプリーチャーん指揮した格好でマウンドに立ちます
トレードマークのノートをリリー閉め作戦は成功するのか
ませんだった
んじゃないか
金正恩
注目のに救命くっ
だけは三方湖一二塁間に飛んだらこれはアウトな2月学校にはてましたがまだ慣れてい
ない相手に掴む消えていないかあります
ちなみにするカードサクセス投手乗ってる石かを意識したそうです
それでも生き目ストレートで入ってくれました
web
しています